Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for officially our 71st episode!
Thank you Ruffians!
And it's a new week too!
Let's do our best to sleep okay?
For some Ruffians that might be joining us for the very first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show.
We try very hard.
Held every Friday.
That's my name.
A.k.a.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts!
What was that, Moco-chan?
Tweet.
Oh.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
I definitely didn't mess up.
No!
No.
You know, it's a Monday morning.
It's okay if you kind of, you know, it's a little bit fuzzy still.
Right.
Was it tough to get out of bed today, Ruffians?
I'm sorry to tell you when you're still so sleepy, Ruffians, but...
There's been another Pero Sighting.
Yeah.
Gonna break the news.
Okay, Moco-chan.
Tell me.
What happened?
Well!
He was spotted.
Here.
This time Pero himself wasn't spotted, but our message with the snow that he left was...
While you're out on a walk.
Wait, you found this in a playground!
Well, I guess it's good that, you know, it'll just eventually melt away.
Yeah.
It's not permanent.
It won't bother anyone for that long.
Yeah, it won't melt that deep.
I'm sure it'll melt away soon.
Right, but you must've just missed crossing paths with Perroccino.
Right!
Oh, you're really lucky.
Oh, that you didn't.
But yeah, you're right.
Because you know, he would've ruined your day for sure.
He's nasty.
Look at the spelling there.
You know, he acts like he's so great.
But yet, you know, he still makes mistakes too.
Although I have to say, at least his handwriting is nice.
BAU BAU!
We're glad you had a nice morning walk too.
No peddle!
Good, good.
BAU BAU!
Oh, Ruffians!
It's finally on!
hololive English is cover of Minecraft!
Please sign up and release on Bii-senpai's channel!
Did you watch the Ruffians?
I know it's a D&D simulator too, but you know maybe there's some Ruffians who are a little busy them too, right?
Right!
Go check it out, okay?
Yeah, go on!
Yeah, you know Minecraft has every member call out English all singing together for the first time.
Right!
And really emotional lyrics too.
It's a really heartwarming cover.
Yeah, you waited a long time.
At least 20 times good, good, good.
Good, good, you know.
It's so colorful and pretty and we all have such cool alternative outfits.
Also to match each other in a very mysterious way.
All similar, all individual.
But I think with Minecraft, though, you can really hear how unique each member's voices are.
And you can also catch some new combinations that you've never heard before, too.
Yeah!
I know!
With Aime-senpai, Nerissa, Moco-chan, and Kiara-senpai.
Yeah!
Right!
You know, it was really wonderful getting to sing together all with everyone.
Right?
Please listen lots, okay?
Yeah.
It makes us really, really, really thankful to be members of hololive English.
BAU BAU!
Again!
Thank you Mei-senpai!
BAU BAU!
We listened at least 10 times!
Why Mumei-senpai's voice is so cool, right?
Kouji-senpai too, I'm very surprised.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I don't know, you might have missed this.
But, the other day, Ao-kun from ReGLOSS held their first one-on-one collab stream with a very special... Secret guest.
Do you know who that was, Ruffians?
The secret guest.
First one-on-one collab.
It was not with my sneeze.
Not with Moco-chan's sneeze, but... Well, it's kind of not that far off, maybe.
That collab partner was none other than AOKU and themselves!
Yeah!
Oh, well, right.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And for a lot of reasons, it was a very, very, very silly stream.
But it seems that Aokun and Aokun here are now being called a dirty FUWAMOCO.
Because of it.
Dirty FUWAMOCO!
That's not very fair, Aokun.
No.
Why?
What do you think, Ruffians?
Yeah.
Not fair, Aokun.
Yeah, that's not right.
That's not right.
Not fair at all.
Right.
And also!
What do you mean?
Dirty FUWAMOCO!
Hai!
No, it sort of makes it sound like we're dirty.
No.
I like to think that there's no such thing as dirty FUWAMOCO.
Yeah.
You know that.
Even if we fall into a pit of mud, that we're not dirty.
So, don't call us dirty FUWAMOCO, okay?
We're FUWAMOCO!
You know, fluffy and fuzzy FUWAMOCO!
Forever and ever.
Right?
No dirty FUWAMOCO, just fluffy and fuzzy FUWAMOCO.
Clean.
BAU BAU!
Not skeevy.
Not sweaty.
Clean.
Definitely was not sweaty.
Definitely not.
BAU BAU!
I've never said such a thing.
No!
Yeah, no.
No dirty FUWAMOCO.
No!
You know that.
You know that, okay.
Ruffians.
You know it.
The other night.
I had a big dream!
Moco-chan's dream.
It's been a little while since you had a dream, right Moco-chan?
But I thought maybe you'd like to hear it.
It's so funny.
So the other night,
I had a dream about our mamas!
Both Mama Puppy and Icomochi-mama!
You know, in the dream, we all went to an amusement park together!
And it was really sunny!
And Mama Puppy and Icomochi-mama were meeting for the first time.
It was fun.
You know, they both really hit it off talking, and I
I was a bit envious because I wanted to talk to Icomochi-mama more too, but...
Mama puppy likes to talk, huh?
Mama puppy was hogging things a little bit.
Yeah.
But you know, before leaving the amusement park, I went with Mama puppy while Fuwawa talked to Icomochi-mama more.
And I went to go buy a souvenir for Icomochi-mama.
But I couldn't find anything nice.
Except for some rings.
I don't know why rings.
Sort of weird, but... And then my dream ended without me choosing anything.
But it was a really nice and sunny dream.
Not a pon-de-ring.
No.
Shiny rings.
No, I woke up and I felt happy.
It was a good dream.
That was a dream.
Yeah.
A nice dream.
That was a good time with...
Mama's right.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Just a happy game, just a game.
It's just silly.
Nothing deep.
Well... I guess, well, you know we talked about Mama Puppy, yeah?
And Ruffians!
You know how we played Thief Simulator 2 the other day, right?
Right!
That was really fun.
Borrowing things.
Borrowing stuff, huh?
Getting tased.
Not so fun.
Not so fun, no!
Yeah!
Well, sometimes thieves, they wear the balaclavas to hide their identities, right?
Yeah.
Right.
Well, actually, FUWAMOCO, we were reminded where our
Maybe you could call it a bit of a trauma, but we have bad memories when we see a BAU BAU.
Well, you see it.
When we were misbehaving.
It really didn't happen that often.
We didn't misbehave much, okay?
We got locked in the cell for mischief.
Yeah, we don't misbehave though, okay?
You know, Papa Puppy used to threaten to chase us around with a balaclava on.
And we were terrified of it.
Howling and running and crying is scary.
Yeah.
It's really, really horrible.
Ruffians are so scary.
Papa Puppy, you know, Papa Puppy doesn't look like Papa Puppy anymore with it on.
Right!
Yeah.
You know, I don't even have any memories of actually being chased on.
It was always just the threat of putting it on that was enough.
Yeah.
I don't know what it is!
I don't know the three weird holes.
Why?
It's just so upsetting.
Right.
There's holes and there's three of them.
Yeah.
But the hats don't have them.
Right.
I don't know.
Even just seeing it afterwards, like laying down, the mask, is scary.
It's scary!
Yeah.
I don't know, Ruffians, do you feel the same way?
Do you feel like it looks upsetting?
Or is it just us?
Do masks scare you?
No, but these do.
No, it's cold, that's why you need one.
Gutsu Kawamori!
No!
FUWAMOCO Balaclavas!
It's just us!
Although I guess they're kind of fluffy and fuzzy in a way, but I definitely know it!
We feel fluffy and fuzzy!
No!
It's just us!
Very cute childhood drama!
Thank you!
Thank you for the compliment!
I guess we're all alone, huh?
A new outfit?
No!
No way!
Icomochi-mama, please don't get ideas.
Don't, don't, don't, don't.
BAU BAU.
I guess it's just us then, huh?
They're terrifying though, Ruffians.
How do you not feel the same way?
They're terrifying.
Hockey masks.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you know, we're
A long, long time.
There's kind of been something missing on FUWAMOCO Morning, right?
So... Uh, what?
Well... Actually, I regret to inform you that there's been a bit of a misunderstanding.
Uh... Yeah... Yeah... You know... We were talking recently about good protagonists, right?
Mm.
Right.
And one Ruffian suggested Subaru Natsuki from ReZero to join that list.
And no, we promptly said NO!
Yeah.
Well, it seems, Ruffians, that some of you are misunderstanding that we said we didn't like ReZero.
That's not what we said.
No.
All we said was just that Subaru Natsuki would definitely not count in our books as a favorite protagonist.
That's what we said, okay?
That's all!
No misunderstanding, okay?
Yeah.
Got it.
Got it on us.
Right.
Right, FUWAMOCO.
Yeah.
But... To tell the truth... We tried watching ReZero as much as we could.
You know, because we were really curious about Rem and Ram.
Spelled blue and pink twins.
You know, it's sort of similar.
We really tried.
We really did.
But we couldn't continue.
To be honest, we kept waiting for Suwako to change, you know, maybe start changing his outlook on things because, you know, we felt like they kept on setting it up for him to have some big change or character growth.
But episode after episode, it didn't happen.
Nope.
Do we miss the Ruffians?
It doesn't happen at all.
Okay, we didn't miss it.
Shall we continue our mission of watching ReZero?
Duh!
He did.
He dies.
He gets better.
Oh.
End of Season 2, but I feel like we watched really, really far!
We definitely got past the end of Season 2.
Give it time?
We gave it so much time!
We gave it a lot of time!
It never gets better.
Okay, decided.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's time to show you a little leak!
It's time to show character growth!
Yup, it's the time for Moco-chan's character growth.
Because she's going to come out with something that's very scary to her.
Not a balaclava.
She's going to eat some natto.
I don't want the Ruffians to think, Oh, Mococo, she's just like Tsugubayashi Natsuki.
No growth at all!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
On standby.
It's not there yet.
But for Ruffians who are just joining us, maybe for the first time today, natto is a Japanese breakfast food that consists of fermented soybeans.
It's really, really healthy for you.
So good for you.
But it's really slimy, and sticky, and a little bit smelly.
It's an SSS.
No.
Sorry, it's my story.
No, stinky smell is sticky.
Was that it?
Yeah.
But Moco-chan's gonna do her best so that she can continue to protect your smile for many, many years to come.
Just like her older sister, Fuwawa, who eats it happily every day.
I wanna eat it happily.
Yeah.
Moco-chan, you feeling good today?
You did so well last time.
I was not feeling good earlier.
But I'm feeling better a bit after seeing the Ruffians.
I'll try.
The Ruffians are gonna make Moco-chan eat a lot of natto today!
Well, I'm gonna stir it up and get it all ready here.
I don't have a tissue.
Oh, that's because you're brave, Moco-chan.
No, I need a tissue.
No, you do not have a tissue.
You will not be getting a tissue today.
You'll just have to eat it like you did last time.
Okay, it's all ready.
It looks pretty nice and sticky today.
But first, Moco-chan, let's say thank you to the farmers in Tochigi who worked very hard to make this natto.
Thank you, farmers!
Okay.
It's my favorite chopsticks.
Yeah, I got them just for you, Moco-chan.
That's good.
Yeah.
Can we have a tissue?
No, I can't reach it.
Also, we only have four left.
If I can't do this, then I'm in trouble.
And you're in trouble, too.
You know, Kano used up a lot of the tissues, so now we have to protect them.
They're endangered.
Yeah.
What?
It hit me!
The smell, it hit me!
What am I gonna do if I can't do this?
You can do it, Moco-chan.
Don't even think about the what if I can't.
Just think of the what if I can.
Yeah.
Think of how proud the Ruffians will be!
Poruru-oneechan will be like, Moco-chan erai yo!
Right!
I'm so happy, can you hear Poruru-oneechan's voice?
I can!
Recently she said, FUWAMOCO daisuki.
And I was happy.
So I think of Poruru-oneechan saying daisuki dayo.
Okay, Moco-chan has one natto.
One natto bean in the chopsticks.
Okay.
Here you go, Moco-chan.
The chopsticks are so sticky, I just want to drop it.
Then just do that.
Like a popcorn.
Okay!
Here you go, Moco-chan!
Five!
Four!
Can you pass me the water?
I don't have a tissue.
I don't have tea.
I need something.
You'll be good.
Just do it.
Five!
Four!
Three!
Two!
One!
Oh!
Oh, she did it, she did it, she did it!
You can do it, Moco-chan!
Keep on going!
Oh!
She did it!
I didn't really chew it though.
No, she chewed it.
Don't cry, Moco-chan.
Another bean?
We should do another bean!
Yeah, you can do it, Moco-chan!
How was it this time?
You did it!
You're averaging one bean every time now.
Right!
So I have a cough drop.
Maya, Moco-chan, you did it!
I'm feeling sweaty now!
No, no, no, no!
No more!
Put some sesame oil on and then you can try to rest.
No!
Cough drop time.
Wow, Ruffians are getting to the point where Moco-chan can eat one natto bean every time.
That's pretty amazing in it's own way.
Improvement.
I already have more character growth than Subaru Natsuki, okay?
Ruffians, make sure to challenge yourself to something new this week too, okay?
BAU BAU!
Next we have our Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Jack-Jack!
Look how sophisticated this puppy is with those glasses!
The red frame glasses!
Very nice!
So stylish!
So cute!
I love it!
And as every puppy is, Jack-Jack loves to play too!
Cute!
I love the sprites.
Oh right!
You wanna poke them, right?
Yeah!
Count them!
Poke, poke, poke.
Sprite, sprite, sprite, sprite.
Oh right!
Well, how does Jack-Jack BAU BAU?
BAU BAU!
I think that's exactly it.
You only have to try.
I don't even have to try.
You got it.
Right.
We should wear glasses.
Jack-Jack feels like a dad.
No, he's a puppy.
I'm not gonna steal Jack-Jack's glasses, okay?
That wouldn't be very nice.
You can't steal stuff from a puppy, okay?
Yeah, that would be bad.
Well, you know, Jack-Jack is a very big cutie with a passion for glasses.
He's still just a puppy, but he's already doing an amazing job at making you and all your family smile!
Cheers!
I think I know, but he's looking forward to playing lots and lots more together with you for many years to come.
BAU BAU!
Well, next I have on today I went on a walk.
I'm going to be going Ruffians.
De-den!
You went on a mountain climb?
At late night.
Please be careful!
But...
The view is nice, huh?
Right?
So many lights.
Romantic.
You say it's a little cloudy, but we still think that's a pretty beautiful view.
Right?
What do you think, Ruffians?
You can see so much!
It's so beautiful.
Right, so pretty.
Oh, it makes you miss your home.
Right?
I don't know, it just feels so familiar, but... I'm glad you had a great time.
But please, please, make sure to be safe and let your loved ones know before you go out on a long hike.
Especially at night, okay?
Right!
You know, safety is always important, okay?
Number one.
We want you to be safe.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Next for our Question of the Day, we have De-den!
Hello Fuwawa, hello Mococo!
Following up from McConnell once again, are you girls the type to have multiple alarms and hit snooze for a while, or do you get up after only one of them?
Do you have multiple alarm clocks to maintain your impeccable streaming schedule?
Thank you!
I do have multiple alarm clocks.
I know.
We really like collecting them.
Sort of like Naegi, but we just don't really use them.
Moco-chan's alarm is really quiet.
Mine is really loud.
I checked all my settings.
I don't know what it is.
Can't figure it out why.
It happens, but at least it works right now.
You know, I kind of like to put my phone in between my mattress and the side of the bunk bed.
And you know, that way it shakes the entire structure and it just, it sounds horrible.
It really does.
But it works well!
You know, at first, after we debuted,
It was hard to sleep for a long time, because you know we were really terrified of oversleeping a stream.
But you know, I think we've gotten used to things now!
And still no oversleeping!
So it's good.
We don't really hit the snooze that much either, I don't think.
Moco-chan hit the snooze today, but...
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for always being a part of FUWAMOCO Morning.
It's really so special to us, so thank you for all your questions, your doggy of the days, your walks, your Pero Sightings, and your FUWAMOCO scoops, too!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Wow.
Moco-chan, we have another stream coming up, right?
Next, we have...
Well today, you know, FUWAMOCO are going to be doing a bunch of recording, homework, and maybe a little bit of rest too if we can.
So wish us luck, okay Ruffians?
You do your best too, okay?
But tomorrow, we'll be seeing our doggy pack for
A little bit of a chat and a little bit of a clean up time.
You know, as we clean up our downloads, I have 13,000 files in my downloads folder and over 600 folders.
So things are sort of hidden.
I need to clean them up.
I can't find the stuff.
So we're gonna have a
A nice time partying up while chatting to yourself.
BAU BAU!
Mama Lucy, you got Ruffians!
And well for our schedule, this week we have a number of exciting things coming up.
A lot of recordings for FUWAMOCO.
But on the weekend, we're gonna be starting Metal Gear Solid 2 on PS2!
Our first time!
First time we have our
PS2 memory cards!
We do it!
I'm all ready.
Controllers too.
Yup.
We're all good to go.
No problems this time.
Yeah.
So we hope you'll join us and, uh, well, hopefully we get the hang of the sneak in part, right?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you!
Our 71st episode, and you know, before we know it, we're gonna blink and we'll be at the 80th episode too!
I feel like we're gonna blink and we're gonna be at 100!
Right?
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Yay!
Moonbeegee.
BAU BAU!
Paijuu.
Zenon.
BAU BAU!
Pandoraphix.
Hongi.
BAU BAU!
Ryusei.
Nekonowatatabi.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!